the Jewish community in the United
States is 20 times as big as the Jewish
community in Britain see have critical
mass we were walking through fifth
avenue as part of the israel parade in
new york now the hundreds of thousands
of people that take part in that we
couldn't possibly assemble that many
people although you know we've done not
badly but the maximum we've ever got
together is 55 thousand Jews in
Trafalgar Square the cheer scale of jury
in America is a quantum leap from what
it is in any European country and that
is that results in enormous diversity
creativity American jury is exciting in
ways that we just don't have the numbers
for
the United States does not have an
archbishop of canterbury it doesn't have
central institutionalized religious
leadership so there's no model on which
the Jewish community could possibly
build the United States is the United
States and I love it Britain is Britain
and it's different I mean we have a
monarch we have you know a House of
Lords all this kind of stuff which just
looks crazy to an American or either
that or very ancient and it is very
ancient but it's very beautiful so I
think each country finds it some way of
being itself and every Jewish community
finds its own way of being Jewish
that that statement really has never
been more untrue it is absolutely clear
today that given the smallness of our
community not only are there more
Muslims than Jews in Britain not only
are there more Hindus than Jews in
Britain there are more seeks than Jews
in Britain and if we continue to want to
have some kind influence we're going to
need the two kinds of representative
voice but we have one is called the
Board of Deputies which defends Jewish
interests but like your conference of
presidents and the other is the chief
Reilly who articulates Judaic principle
so given that the world is more unstable
Europe especially than ever before I
think every other religious community
envies us for this particular office
Muslims the six and the Hindus would
love to have such a thing but they are
not constituted to do it and so what
they don't